This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Eric Mollinsky has reported a few episodes for us over the years, and he has his own great podcast called Imaginary Worlds that we've featured a couple of times. Imaginary Worlds has a very special place in my heart because it is the podcast I listen to the most with my boys, Maslow and Carver, because it covers all the sci-fi and fantasy subjects that they love, like D&D and Doctor Who and LARPING, in a really thoughtful and entertaining way. And like every great show, it's about those things, but it's really about who we are as humans through these worlds that we create and share.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是Roman Mars。Eric Mollinsky多年来为我们报道过几期节目，他自己也有一档很棒的播客叫《Imaginary Worlds》，我们曾推荐过几次。《Imaginary Worlds》在我心中有着非常特殊的地位，因为这是我和我的孩子们Maslow和Carver一起听得最多的播客，因为它涵盖了他们喜爱的所有科幻和奇幻主题，比如《龙与地下城》（D&D）、《神秘博士》（Doctor Who）和LARP（实景角色扮演游戏），而且内容既深刻又有趣。和所有优秀的节目一样，它虽然是在讲这些东西，但实际上是通过我们创造和分享的这些世界，来探讨我们作为人类的本质。
Now earlier this year, a imaginary world's produced a story about the thing that is most near and dear to my boys' hearts. And that's the card game, magic, the gathering. I just called magic a card game, but if you spend any time around someone who loves magic, you know it is way more than a card game. It is a way of life. I'm pretty sure it rewired my son's brains. I've wanted to cover magic on 99PI for a while now, but Eric did such a great job with
今年早些时候，《Imaginary Worlds》制作了一期关于我孩子们最心爱之物的节目，那就是集换式卡牌游戏《万智牌》（Magic: The Gathering）。我刚才把它称为卡牌游戏，但如果你和任何热爱《万智牌》的人相处过，你就会知道它远不止是一个卡牌游戏。它是一种生活方式。我很确定它重塑了我儿子的大脑。我一直想在《99PI》上介绍《万智牌》，但Eric做得太出色了，
it. It made more sense to share his version and introduce you to another great podcast that you might not know already. Okay. Enjoy. You're listening to Imaginary Worlds. A show about how we create them and why we suspend or disbelieve. I'm Eric Mollinsky.
以至于直接分享他的版本，并向大家介绍另一档你们可能还不知道的优秀播客，显得更有意义。好了，请欣赏。你正在收听的是《Imaginary Worlds》。这是一档关于我们如何创造这些世界以及为何要进行“怀疑悬置”的节目。我是Eric Mollinsky。
And this is Nat. Hello. My name is Nat. Hello, my name is Nat Neal Bale. Nat is teaching me how to play Magic the Gathering at the Brooklyn Strategist, which is the same game shop where I learned to play Dungeons and Dragons a few years ago. But where D&D is a role-playing game, magic is very much a card game. And by the way, magic is the shorthand
这位是Nat。你好。我叫Nat。你好，我叫Nat Neal Bale。Nat正在Brooklyn Strategist教我如何玩《万智牌》，这也是几年前我学习玩《龙与地下城》的那家游戏店。但《龙与地下城》是角色扮演游戏，而《万智牌》则更像是一款卡牌游戏。顺便说一下，“Magic”是大多数人对《万智牌》（Magic: The Gathering）的简称。所以在这期节目中，我大部分时间会称它为“Magic”。从最基础的层面来看，《万智牌》有两种基本卡牌：地牌和咒语牌。在某些方面，《万智牌》和其他卡牌游戏一样。你需要运气和技巧的结合才能获胜，而且通常是两人对战。但它不是一副普通的扑克牌。每张牌上都有一个生物、一个咒语或一件魔法神器，你可以用它们来攻击对手。有些牌代表你魔法的来源，也就是地牌。你拥有的地牌越多，你能对坐在对面的人施展的魔法就越强大。而你的
that most people call magic the Gathering. So I'm going to mostly call it magic in this episode. At the simplest level, there are two basic types of cards in magic, lands and spells. In some ways, magic is like any card game. You need a combination of luck and skill to win, and it's usually played with just two people. But it is not a generic deck of cards. Each of the cards has a creature, or a spell, or magical artifact on it that you can use to attack your opponent. And some cards represent the source of your magic, which are lands. The more land cards that you have, the more magic you can wield against the person sitting across from you. And your
目标是将对手的生命值从20点降至0点。这并不简单。真的不简单。真的，真的非常不简单。所以当你玩的时候，你手里总是拿着从60张牌的牌库中抽出的7张牌。嗯，那60张牌的牌库是你自己定制的，因为制作《万智牌》的公司，
goal is to knock your opponent from 20 points to zero points. It's not simple. It's not. It's really, really not. So when you play, you always have seven cards in your hand that you're taking from a deck of 60 cards. Well, that deck of 60 cards is something that you custom make because the company that makes magic the gathering,
威世智（Wizards of the Coast），在过去四分之一个世纪里已经推出了超过10,000种可供选择的卡牌。而且有一个核心神话将这成千上万张卡牌联系在一起，因为《万智牌》发生在一个多元宇宙中。其中一些卡牌代表“鹏洛客”（Planeswalkers），即游戏的主角，
Wizards of the Coast, has put out over 10,000 possible cards to choose from over the last quarter century. And there is a central mythology that unites those thousands and thousands of cards, because Magic the Gathering takes place in a multiverse. And some of the cards represent plain walkers, the main characters of the game
他们可以从一个平行宇宙跳跃到另一个平行宇宙。我一直知道《万智牌》非常庞大，但我从未做过关于它的节目，因为我有点被它吓到了。比如，当我以前去Brooklyn Strategist玩《龙与地下城》时，我们会像在中世纪即兴表演剧团里那样扮演角色吗？然后我会看向那些玩《万智牌》的人坐的桌子，感觉他们好像在说一种完全不同的语言。今年是《万智牌》诞生25周年，
can jump from one parallel universe to another. Now, I always knew that Magic the Gathering was huge, but I had never done an episode about it because I was kind of intimidated. Like, when I used to go to the Brooklyn Stratagist to play D&D, would I be roleplaying our characters like we're in some kind of medieval improv troupe? And then I'd look at the table where these people were playing Magic the Gathering, and it was like they were speaking a whole other language. Now this year is a 25th anniversary
游戏至今依然如此受欢迎，这让我感到惊讶。并不是说游戏本身有什么问题，但它是由一位名叫Richard Garfield的数学家在90年代初开发的，当时电子游戏的竞争还很小。而现在，许多曾经非常稳固的模拟游戏和玩具都在努力与PlayStation和iPad应用竞争。虽然《万智牌》也有应用，但实体卡牌游戏仍然是核心。而且他们并没有在竞争中挣扎。我的意思是，《万智牌》一直处于史诗般的增长中，
of Magic the Gathering, and it amazes me the game is still so popular. Now that there's anything wrong with the game itself, but it was developed by this mathematician named Richard Garfield in the early 90s, and there's very little competition from video games. And now so many analog games and toys that used to be pretty solid are struggling to compete against play stations and iPad apps. And Magic does have an app, but the handheld card game is still the main focus. And they are not struggling to compete. I mean, Magic the Gathering has been on an epic run,
每年的利润都比前一年高。所以我对这款游戏有两个非常好奇的问题。首先，为什么它能在数字娱乐的冲击下幸存下来？其次，在一个非线性的卡牌游戏中，你如何创造出故事感和世界观？所有这些神话和世界观构建会让游戏变得更好吗？还是说玩家在专注于获胜时会忽略这些？为了回答这些问题，我直接找到了《万智牌》的首席设计师Mark Rosewater。
where each year is more profitable than the last. So I had two questions about the game I was really curious about. First, why has it survived the onslaught of digital entertainment? And secondly, how do you create a sense of story in world building in a non-sequential card game? And does all that mythology in world building make for a better card game? Or is it something the players ignore when they just focus on winning? Well to answer those questions, I went straight to the top to the head designer for Magic
我又在开车去上班的路上了。我们都知道这意味着什么。是时候开始他们的“上班路上的谈话”（Drive to Work）了。顺便说一下，这就是他播客每一集的开头方式，他在开车去西雅图郊外办公室的路上，谈论游戏的各个方面。他不仅仅做播客。Mark活跃在每一个媒体平台上，谈论《万智牌》，回答玩家的问题。他是一个充满个性的人。Mark从90年代中期，也就是《万智牌》推出几年后就加入了公司。我必须说，在我采访过的这么多年里，我想我从未见过像Mark这样毫不掩饰地
the Gathering, Mark Rosewater. I'm pulling another driveway. We all know what that means. It's time for their drive to work. By the way, that is how we start every episode of his podcast, as he drives to the office outside Seattle, talking about different aspects of the game. And he doesn't just do a podcast. Mark is out there on every media platform talking about magic, answering questions from players. He is a force of personality. Now, Mark has been with the companies since the mid 90s, just a few years after Magic the Gathering came out. And I have to say, in all of my years of interviewing people. I don't think I've ever met anybody who so unabashedly
热爱自己工作的人。我的工作是想出一些非常酷的东西，让玩家感到非常非常兴奋，然后我通常得在16到24个月内对此守口如瓶。例如，去年12月，我们发布了一个名为《Unstable》的产品，这是一种类似幽默风格的《万智牌》。我为这个项目工作了七年，我不得不对此保密了七年。所以当我终于可以谈论它时，人们说：“哇，你太兴奋了。”我说：“我已经等了七年才谈论它。”
loves their job as much as Mark does. My job is to come up with really cool things that will make players really, really excited and then I have to not talk about it for 16 to 24 months usually. For example, last December, we put out a product called Unstable, which is kind of like a humorous take on magic. I've been working on this project for seven years, and I had to not talk about it for seven years. And so when I finally got to talk about people like, wow, you're so excited. I'm like, I've been waiting to talk about it for seven years.
《万智牌》多年来保持受欢迎的原因之一是游戏从未停止进化。正如我之前提到的，游戏的前提是有被称为“时空”（Planes）的平行宇宙。威世智引入这些新时空的频率已经从每几年一次，变成每年一次，现在有时一年两次。
Now, one of the reasons why magic has stayed popular all these years is because the game never stops evolving. As I mentioned earlier, the premise of the game is that there are these parallel universes called planes. And the frequency in which Wizards of the Coast has introduced these new planes has gone from every couple of years to every year to now sometimes twice a year.
你知道，起初《万智牌》依赖于你在《龙与地下城》这类游戏中看到的标准奇幻套路。但随着他们越来越快地引入新世界，他们有点用完了那些奇幻套路。因此，他们在引入奇幻类型的内容时也必须更具创造力。比如在其中一个平行宇宙中，一切都是金属做的。或者另一个平行时空就像是蒸汽朋克版的印度。但正如Mark所说，一套卡牌是一种非常有挑战性的讲故事方式。
And you know, in the beginning, magic was relying on all the standard fantasy tropes that you would see in a game like Dungeons and Dragons. But as they kept introducing new worlds more and more quickly, they kind of ran out of those fantasy tropes. And so they've also had to be more creative in terms of what they bring into the fantasy genre. Like in one of these parallel universes, everything's made of metal. Or another one of these parallel planes is like a steam punk version of India. But as Mark says, A set of cards is a very challenging way to tell a story.
并不是每个人都能看到每一张牌，而且他们看到的顺序也不一样。所以我们倾向于利用卡牌来构建环境，构建世界，充实世界，并暗示故事，然后我们倾向于通过其他方式来讲述故事。比如在《万智牌》的网站上，有很多额外的材料来解释这些不同世界中正在发生的事情。
Not everybody sees every card and they don't see them in the same order. So what we've done is we tend to use our cards to build the environment, to build the world, to flesh out the world, and hint at the story, and then we tend to tell the story through other means. Like on the Magic the Gathering website, there's a lot of extra material explaining what is going on in these different worlds.
但最终，他们决定提高卡牌设计的门槛。所以当你遇到一副新牌组时，你会自动对这个世界产生某种感觉，而无需阅读背后的背景故事。我们想弄清楚这种体验的情感核心是什么，机制不仅仅是为了做某事，而是为了让你感受到某种东西。它真正触及了这样的想法：我们要去一个哥特式恐怖世界，我们要让你感到恐惧，因为这是一个哥特式
But eventually, they decided to up the ante on the design of the cards. So when you encounter a new deck, you automatically feel something about this world without having to read the backstory behind it. We want to figure out what the emotional core of the experience is going to be, that the mechanics aren't just about doing something, they're about making you feel something. And it really got into the idea of, we're going to go to a Gothic horror world and we're going to make you afraid because it's a Gothic
恐怖世界。或者我们要去一个希腊神话世界，你将成为一名英雄，去冒险并成就一番事业。每张卡牌有三个基本要素。首先是插图，大约两英寸见方。但在那些小画作中蕴含着如此多的戏剧性和故事。看着它们，我会被吸引进去，就像在看电影一样。每张卡牌的第二个要素是统计数据，即这个生物、咒语或神器作为卡牌将如何运作。
horror world. Or we're going to go to a Greek mythology world and you're going to be a hero and go in adventures and make something of yourself. Now there are three basic elements to each card. First, there's an illustration, which is about two by two inches. But there's so much drama and story going on in those little paintings. I mean, looking at them, I get sucked in like it's a movie. The second element to every card is the statistics as to how this creature or spell or artifact will function as a card.
我以前没意识到一张牌在游戏中可以有这么多不同的表现方式。我的意思是，关于你获得或扣除对手多少点数，这张牌是更适合进攻还是防守，你可以使用这张牌多少次，这些方面是无穷无尽的，而且游戏机制不是随机的。它们反映了卡牌上事物的个性。每张卡牌的第三个主要要素是所谓的
And I did not realize how many different ways a card could behave in a game. I mean, it is endless in terms of how many points you gain or take away from your opponent, whether this card is better used on the offensive or the defensive, how many times you can use the card, and the game mechanics aren't random. They reflect the personality of what's on the card. And the third major element to every card is something called
“风味文字”（Flavor text），基本上是几行诗意的描述。但即使是风味文字多年来也变得更有野心了，不是指他们能在卡牌里塞进多少字，而是简单地说，他们如何能在这一张牌之外描绘出一个宏大的故事？以前我写风味文字时，其中一点是它很像诗歌，很像我如何在最小的空间内传达尽可能多的信息。我最喜欢的风味文字之一，是在一套名为《冰雪时代》（Ice Age）的系列中，我们去了一个冰冷的世界，里面有一张牌叫Lurgoyf，这是一个可怕的怪物，大致基于一些北欧传说。
flavor text, which are basically a few lines of poetic description. But even the flavor text has gotten more ambitious over the years, not in terms of how many words they can cram into a card. But how's this, simply, they can paint a picture of a broad story beyond that one card? Back when I used to write flavor text, one of the things was it was a lot like poetry, it was a lot like how can I convey as much as possible in the smallest amount of space. And one of my favorite pieces of flavor text, there's a card in a set called, we went to this icy world, it was called Ice Age, and there's a card in it called Lurgoyf, which was this horrible monster, loosely based on some Norse stuff.
上面的风味文字是：“Akhans run its filergoyf”，这是Safi Arags女儿的遗言。不知何故，这个想法——这个可怜的女人，我们关于她了解到的最后一件事是她被吓坏了，因为她知道这个生物有多可怕，而她是正确的，因为那是她说的最后一句话。尽管Mark喜欢谈论游戏，但他实际上最热衷的一个方面是所谓的“颜色派”（Color Pie）。当我第一次读到颜色派时，它似乎只是整个游戏机制中一种深奥的部分。但后来我意识到它
The flavor text on it was, Akhans run its filergoyf, last words of Safi Arags' daughter. And somehow just like this idea that this poor woman, the last thing we learn about her is she's scared to death because she knows how horrible this creature is and she is right because that's the last thing she ever says. And as much as Mark loves to talk about the game, there's one aspect that he's actually the most passionate about. It's called the Color Pie. And when I first read about the Color Pie, it just seemed like sort of an esoteric part of the whole game mechanics. But then I realized it
是游戏的生命线。正是它让你在玩卡牌时感觉自己真的在施展魔法。因为《万智牌》中的所有卡牌都分为五种颜色。卡牌要么是白色、黑色、蓝色、红色或绿色。每种颜色代表一种不同的魔法哲学。所以白魔法关乎控制、秩序和任何对集体利益有益的事物。黑魔法推崇无情的个人主义。红魔法是炽热而充满激情的。蓝魔法是聪明的、理性的。
is the lifeblood of the game. It is the thing that makes you feel like you're actually wielding magic when you play with the cards. Because all of the cards, and magic the gathering, are divided into five colors. The cards are either white, black, blue, red, or green. In each color represents a different philosophy of magic. So white magic is about control, order, and whatever works for the collective good. Black magic promotes ruthless individualism. Red magic is fiery and passionate. Blue magic is brainy, intellectual.
绿魔法与自然和谐相处。关于颜色派，我喜欢的一点是，它以一种不贬低动机的方式解释了动机。比如，有一件非常有趣的事情，它让我对生活有了些许不同的思考，那就是没有人是绝对正确或错误的，他们只是有理由以他们的方式做事。
Green magic is in harmony with nature. One of the neat things about the color pie that I love is it explains motivations in a way that doesn't demean the motivations. Like one of the things that's really interesting, it's made me think about life a little differently is nobody's right or wrong, they just have a reason for doing the things
就像是，哦，他们的动机是什么？嗯，如果你是被这个所驱动的，那么你与被那个所驱动的人发生冲突就是合情合理的。我可以争论，而且我也确实争论过。我可以从任何角度为任何颜色辩护。比如我为了好玩做的一件事是，
the way they do them. And it's like, oh, what are their motivations? And well, if you're motivated by this, then it makes sense you come in conflict who's motivated by that. I can argue and I have. I can argue any color from any perspective. Like one of the things I did for fun at
因为我是个作家，我在文章中做了一次采访，我用一整栏的篇幅采访了每一种颜色，让这种颜色从他们的角度解释他们为什么做他们所做的事情。那么，当我在游戏店里向我的导师Nat学习时，这一切是如何展开的呢？每种颜色都有非常独特的个性和游戏玩法。比如，你使用的颜色往往决定了你的牌组做什么。在我的第一局游戏中，我用了一副
because I'm a writer is I did an interview interview in my articles where I spent a whole column with each of the colors interviewing the colors, having the color explain from their perspective why they do what they do. So how did this all play out back at the game shop when I was learning how to play from my instructor, Nat? Each color has a very distinct personality and gameplay. Like, the colors you use tend to define what your deck does. Now, in my first game, I played with a deck of cards
全是红色的牌组。所以我使用的魔法是炽热且冲动的。这是我玩游戏时的本能，这也是我经常输的原因，因为每当我应该进行战略思考时，冲动行事就是我的败笔。与此同时，Nat用的是一副黑魔法牌组，它全都是关于吸取对手的能量并为自己所用。“你要从目标木乃伊那里受到一点伤害吗？”“好吧，你只剩一点生命值了，所以我死了。”
where everything was red. So the magic I was using was fiery and impulsive. And that's my natural instinct when I play games, which is why I often lose, because going on impulse is my downfall whenever I'm supposed to be thinking strategically. Meanwhile, Nat was playing with a deck of black magic, which is all about sucking away your opponent's energy and using it for yourself. And you're gonna take one damage from the target mummy? Well, you only have one point left, so I'm dead.
Brady Dommermuth是《万智牌》创意团队的首席作家。他说，当他致力于开发一套新卡牌时，他总是思考他们通过卡牌讲述的故事应该如何反映人们玩卡牌的体验。《万智牌》挑战了奇幻文学中最常见的道德准则之一。我的意思是，奇幻故事中基本的道德信息往往是：当然，你是天选之子，注定要拯救世界，但你需要朋友的帮助才能做到。但在《万智牌》中，我觉得在故事和世界设计方面，形式需要
Uh, Brady Dommerm youth was a lead writer on the creative team of magic. And he says when he would work on developing a new set of cards, he always thought about how the story they're telling with the cards should reflect the experience of people playing with the cards. Magic defies one of the most common ethos prescriptions in fantasy. And by that, I mean, was the basic moral message of the story in fantasy a lot of times is, sure, you're the chosen one and you're destined to save the world, but you're going to need your friends to help you out in doing so. But in magic, I felt like in terms of the story and the world design that form needed
服从功能。在《万智牌》中，绝大多数游戏是1对1的。是你对阵我。是我的牌组对阵你的牌组。要么你赢，要么我赢。这对我来说暗示了一种不同的道德观，那就是：当然，你必须有朋友。这非常重要，但在最终的战斗中，当关键时刻到来时，你必须独自战斗。
to follow function. And in magic, the vast majority of games are played one versus one. It's you versus me. It's my deck versus your deck. And either you're going to win or I'm going to win. Which to me, it suggested a different ethos, which is sure, of course, you have to have friends. That's super important, but in the final fight, when it matters, you're going to have to fight alone.
事实上，他认为《万智牌》经常被误认为是奇幻游戏，因为传统上，奇幻文学在道德上一直是非黑即白的。但当你玩《万智牌》时，如果你使用黑魔法，你并不自动成为反派；如果你使用白魔法，你也不自动成为英雄。从这个意义上说，你认为《万智牌》实际上反映了科幻小说，科幻小说有着道德模糊的悠久历史。Mark Rosewater和我多次谈论过《星球大战》是如何披着科幻外衣的奇幻故事，而
In fact, he thinks that magic is often misrepresented as a fantasy game, because traditionally, fantasy has been pretty black and white in its morality. But when you play magic the gathering, you're not automatically a villain if you use black magic, and you're not automatically the hero if you use white magic. In that sense, you think magic the gathering actually reflects science fiction, which is a long history of being morally ambiguous. Mark Rosewater and I have talked about that many times about how Star Wars is a fantasy story in sci-fi clothing whereas
《万智牌》则是披着奇幻外衣的科幻故事。回到游戏店。我用了红魔法，结果输了，所以我开始使用一副蓝色的牌组，其中的咒语和生物更聪明、更狡猾。顺便说一下，当你玩游戏时，你实际上可以使用任何颜色的组合，但因为我是新手，Nat觉得我应该一次只玩一种颜色。当我从红魔法切换到蓝魔法时，我简直不敢相信卡牌的运作方式竟然如此不同。
Magic is a sci-fi story and fantasy clothing Back to the game shop. I use red magic and I lost so I started using a deck of blue cards with the spells and creatures are brainier and trickier. And by the way, when you play the game, you actually can play any combination of colors, but since I was a newbie, Nat felt that I should just play one color at a time. And when I switched from red magic to blue magic, I couldn't believe how differently the cards worked.
我觉得我在依赖大脑的不同部分，而我的导师Nat也从黑魔法切换到了白魔法，我觉得我是在和一个完全不同的对手对战。“我现在感到不知所措。”“抱歉，魔法就是这样。”“不，没关系。有很多，每一张牌都有很多层次。”
And I felt like I was relying on a different part of my brain, and my teacher, Nat, had also switched from black magic to white magic and I felt like I was playing against a different opponent. I feel overwhelmed right now. Sorry, magic can do this. No, it's fine. There's so many, every card has so many levels to it.
“是的，没关系。这个游戏需要很长时间才能学会。这是一个非常、非常复杂的游戏。”但就在那时，我意识到故事是如何融入其中的，因为要成为一名优秀的《万智牌》玩家，你需要知道为什么你的卡牌会有那样的表现。要做到这一点，去《万智牌》网站阅读卡牌背后的传说非常有帮助。
Yep, it's all good. This game takes so long time to learn. It's a very, very complex game. But that's when I realized how story can come into this, because to be a good magic player, you need to know why your cards behave the way they do. And to do that, it's really helpful to go on the magic website and read the lore behind your cards.
我相信，过去五年左右故事推动的方向之一，是让卡牌更积极地反映故事事件。这样，仅仅通过玩游戏和观察卡牌的作用，你就能有效地了解故事的走向。事实上，在网上，我发现一些《万智牌》玩家创作了同人艺术，他们想象如果《哈利·波特》或漫威电影宇宙，
One of the pushes in the stories in the last five years or so, I believe, was to make the cards reflect story events more aggressively. So that by just by playing the game and watching what the cards do, you can effectively learn how the story went. In fact, online, I found that some magic players had created fan art, where they imagined what if Harry Potter or the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
变成了《万智牌》的卡牌会怎样？在这些我们非常熟悉的角色中，比如哈利·波特或雷神，看到他们如何被浓缩成一张卡牌，并用插图、关于他们的力量、弱点和能力的统计数据以及几行精选的风味文字来总结，真是太酷了。但当他在创意团队工作时，Brady Dommermuth始终牢记，《万智牌》不是为了做成游戏而反向工程的电影或书籍。它首先是一款游戏。
were cards and magic the gathering? In these characters that we know so well, like Harry Potter, or Thor, it's kind of cool to see how they could be condensed into a single card, and summarized with an illustration, a bunch of statistics about their strengths, weaknesses, and powers, and a few choice lines of flavor text. But when he was working on the creative team, Brady Dommermuth always kept in mind that magic is not a movie or a book reverse engineered to be a game. It is, first and foremost, a game.
对我来说，设计《万智牌》世界的一个挑战，我低估情节的原因之一是，我认为情节和游戏不是朋友。你的自主导向能力，你做出自己想做选择的能力，你按照自己认为合适的方式探索世界的能力，或者为自己的牌组选择卡牌的能力，或者决定你是想通过技巧、潜行还是蛮力来赢得游戏的能力。这些都是非常强大的东西，而情节会颠覆自主权。我在第二轮游戏中了解到，这种蓝色的智力型魔法非常适合我。我避免了所有最坏的冲动，并成为了一个更好的战略家。事实上……
One of the challenges for me in designing magic worlds, one of the reasons why I undervalued plot is because I think that plot and games are not friends, your ability to self-direct, your ability to make the choices that you want to make, your ability to explore the world how you see fit, or to choose the cards for your own deck, or to decide how you want to win the game through a finesse, or through stealth, or through brute force. Those are super powerful things and plots subverts autonomy. And I learned in my second round of playing the game that this blue intellectual magic was a good fit for me. I avoided all my worst impulses and I became a better strategist. In fact...
“但我们也有这个问题，我从‘魔力斯芬克斯’那里受到了8点伤害，我的生命值只剩2点了。”“所以你死了。”“是的，真是太棒了。”“游戏结束了。”“天哪，我简直不敢相信。”“是的，我绝对要退出平局。我不会再打第二局了。我不会去打剩下的三局了。”《万智牌》传奇还有更多内容，包括一些成长的烦恼和狂热粉丝带来的奇怪陷阱。此外，你还会听到几个总是有话要说的孩子的声音。
But we also have this issue of I take sphinx of eight damage from sphinx of m agocy to my two life So you're dead. Yeah, what a bit Wow So game over that Oh my god, I can't believe it Yeah, I'm definitely quitting at the tie. I'm not gonna go for two. I'm not gonna go for the rest of three quitting at the tie. I'm not going to go for two. I'm not going to go for the rest of three. There is more to the magic saga including some growing pains and the strange pitfalls of intense fandom. Plus, you're going to hear from a couple of kids who always have something to say.
当《Imaginary Worlds》在《99% Invisible》中继续时。我是Eric Mollinsky。Liz Leo曾经在《万智牌》担任图形设计师。这对她来说是一份梦想的工作，但也意味着要接受大量的审查。当我有数百万人看到我的第一个扩展符号或我的第一个卡牌框架设计，并随后抱怨他们不喜欢的地方时，我会提醒自己，有数百万人正在使用我设计的东西，是的，有些人会直言不讳地表示不喜欢，但这恰恰说明他们有多在乎他们正在玩的游戏。但我也不能粉饰太平。我的意思是，确实有一些有毒的玩家，威世智已经封禁了他们，或者至少一直在努力处理他们的
When imaginary worlds on 99% of visible continues after this. worlds on 99% of visible continues after this. From imaginary worlds here again is Eric Mullensky. Liz Leo used to work as a graphic designer on Magic Gathering. And this was a dream job for her, but it also meant a lot of scrutiny. When I had millions of people see my first expansion symbol or my first card frame design and then consequently complain about what they didn't like about it, I'd remind myself that millions of people were playing with this thing I designed and yeah, some people are going to be vocal and not like it, but it just shows how much they care about the game that they're playing. But I can't sugarcoat it either. I mean, there are certainly some toxic players and Wizards has banned them or at least been working on their
但随后她也会遇到这样的时刻，她曾经去参加一个活动，坐下来玩游戏。“坐在我对面的那个人在我们轮抽时问我是怎么接触到《万智牌》的。”我觉得这是一个很好的问题，我就回答并告诉了他答案。答案是你从一个名为“Lady Planeswalker Society”的全女性团体那里学会了玩游戏。但那个人似乎并不在意。他只是说：“呵，我没想到女生会喜欢《万智牌》。”对话就这样结束了。
but then she has moments like this where she once went to an event and sat down to play a game. The guy across from you while we were drafting asked how I got into magic. And I thought that was a nice question and I responded and told him the answer. The answer is that you learned to play from an all-female group called the Lady Plains Walker Society. But the guy didn't seem to care. He just said, huh, I didn't think girls were into magic. And that was the end of the conversation.
多么微小且无害的评论。在他的脑海里，他可能根本没觉得这有什么，但我仍然记得它，因为它让我感觉更像是在想：“哇，我不应该在这里吗？”当你已经在玩一个需要你在思维和策略上百分之百投入的游戏时，这可能是一个需要克服的障碍。随着科幻奇幻空间多年来变得越来越包容，出现了一些反弹。在电子游戏、雨果奖、Cosplay、星球大战粉丝圈中，以及
What a small and innocuous comment. In his head, he probably didn't even think it was anything, but I still remember it, because it just made me feel even more a little bit like, wow, should I not be here? And when you're already playing a game where you have to be 100% on your A game in terms of your mind and strategy, it can be a hurdle to overcome. As sci-fi fantasy spaces have become more inclusive over the years, there's been a nougat backlash. In video games, the Hugo Book Awards, Cosplay, Star Wars fandom, and
像《万智牌》这样庞大的社区也未能幸免于这些问题。但话虽如此，这款游戏自诞生以来一直因卡牌上拥有多元化的角色而受到赞誉，但随着时间的推移，创意团队意识到他们需要更加包容。Allie Medwin是一位主要在《万智牌》数字部门工作的编辑和设计师。几年前，一位实习生向她提出了一个想法。如果他们为正在开发的新牌组创造一个跨性别角色会怎样？
a huge community like Magic the Gathering has not been immune to those problems. But that said, the game has always gotten praised since the beginning for having diverse characters on the cards, but over time the creative team realized that they needed to be even more inclusive. Allie Medwin is an editor and designer who mostly works in Magic's digital division. And a few years ago, an intern came up to her with an idea. What if they created a trans character for a new deck that they're working on?
“我意识到这就是我们想要的代表性。这是一个非常自然的流程，这不是强行植入的，这不是象征性的，这是对这个设定中已经确立的事物的自然延伸。”他们把这个想法带给了故事团队的资深创意设计师James Wyatt。结果这成了他们两人的个人项目。Allie是跨性别者，尽管她当时还没有出柜。对于James来说，“我的女儿是跨性别者，所以我说，为了她，我需要写这个故事。”
I realized this is what we want representation to look like. This is a pretty natural flow, like this is not shoehorned in, this is not tokenized, this is a natural extension of already established things about this setting. They brought the idea to James Wyatt, who is a senior creative designer on the story team. And this turned out to be a personal project for both of them. Allie is trans, although she wasn't out at the time. And it's for James. My daughter is trans, so I said, I need to write this story for her sake.
Allie和James真的希望这个角色，也就是Alesha，成为一名勇猛的战士。事实上，这张牌的官方标题是“Alesha, Who Smiles at Death”（微笑面对死亡的Alesha）。卡牌上的插图显示Alesha身穿全套盔甲，带领她的Mardu氏族军队冲锋。在《万智牌》中，我喜欢我们游戏的一点是，我们倾向于不在女性角色身上加装“胸甲”。所以你看不出她的生理结构是什么样的。James为网站写了背景故事，
Ali and James, really one of this character, is called Alesha to be a fierce warrior. In fact, the card's official title is Alesha, who smiles at death. In the illustration on the card, shows Alessia in full armor, leading the charge with her army of the Mardou clan. One of the things in magic that I love about our game is that we don't tend to put boob plate on our women. So you can't really tell what her physiology looks like. James wrote the backstory for the website,
他们争论最大的情节点是，是否应该让一个反派就Alesha的身份与她对质。有一种感觉，而且自从故事发表以来，我也听到一些人这么说，也许如果Alesha只是被接受为她自己，而没有任何疑问，那会更好。
and the biggest plot point that they argued over was whether an antagonist should confront a Lesha about her identity. There was some sense, and I've heard some people say this since the story was published, that maybe it would have been better if a Lesha was just accepted for who she is with no question at all.
但我们最终在故事中加入了一个挑战她的角色，说“你只是一个不知道自己是谁的男孩”，这是一句非常糟糕、可怕的话。对于我的女儿来说，这一点非常重要，因为她希望有一个角色能意识到Alesha的价值、尊严和她作为她自己的身份。我记得早期讨论过的一件有趣的小事是，Alesha非常适合Mardu氏族，原因有二：一是他们认领战争名字的想法，二是他们不使用蓝魔法的事实。因为在《万智牌》的世界里，如果你能使用蓝魔法，蓝色在某种程度上与转化有关。
But we did end up with a character in the story who challenges her and says you're just a boy who doesn't know who he is, which is a terrible awful thing to say. And to my daughter, it was really important that that was there because she wanted to have a character come to realize Alessia's worth and value and identity as who she is. A funny little thing I remember discussing early on is that Alessia was a good fit for the Mardu for two reasons and one is that idea that they claim a war name and the other is the fact that they don't use Blue magic. Because in the world of magic, the gathering, if you have access to blue magic, blue is partially about transformation.
所以改变你的身份、改变你的外表、改变你的身体实际上会非常容易。我们希望她的经历能更好地反映现实世界中跨性别者在没有蓝魔法的情况下所经历的体验。“是的，我告诉你，如果我有蓝魔法，我的人生可能会有所不同，很多人的生活可能会有所不同。”我女儿甚至设计了一个《龙与地下城》的咒语，允许进行永久性的转变。不错。
And so it would actually be really easy to change your identity, change your appearance, change your body. And we wanted her experience to reflect better the experience of real trans people in this world without access to blue magic. Yeah, I'll tell you what, if I had blue magic, my life might have gone a little differently, a lot of people's lives might have gone a little differently. My daughter has actually designed a D&D spell that will allow that as a permanent transition. Nice.
当他们最终发布这张卡牌时，他们对《万智牌》社区的反应感到有些紧张。但反响非常积极，以至于我想到这里还会流泪。它是压倒性地积极。可能50条评论中只有一条是负面的。绝大多数都是积极的。这个角色Alesha的创造也对Allie产生了巨大的影响。“我长期以来一直过着电子游戏玩家所说的‘隐身’（stealth）生活。也就是说，我不谈论自己是跨性别者，我不让别人知道。我把它作为一个秘密，但并没有主动撒谎。”
When they finally put the card out there, they were a little nervous about how the magic community would react. But there was so much positive reaction that I still cry thinking about it. It was overwhelmingly positive. Maybe one comment in 50 was negative. The overwhelming majority was positive. The creation of this character, Elisha, also had a big impact on Ali. I lived what Electronics people call stealth for a long time. That is, I didn't talk about being trans, I didn't let people know. I kept it a secret without actively lying about it.
我在这个过程进行到一半时出柜了，这非常有意义。这令人难以置信地如释重负。没有Alesha，我可能仍然会选择隐身，看吧，我不会说这对某些人不起作用，因为它确实有效，但我把它视为一种负担，而Alesha能够将我从中拯救出来。但Alesha不仅仅是故事中的角色，她还是游戏中的角色。游戏机制很酷。我的意思是，她可以帮助你复活你已经用过的其他卡牌。这就是Allie真正欣赏《万智牌》的地方，游戏机制激发角色发展，反之亦然。
I came out about halfway through the process and it was incredibly rewarding. It was incredibly relieving. Without a Lesha, I would still probably be stealth, which, look, I'm not going to say it doesn't work for some people because it does, but I felt it as a burden and a Lesha was able to save me from that. But Alisha isn't just a character in a story, she's a character in a game. Inter game mechanics are cool. I mean, she can help you resurrect other cards that you've already used up. And that's something that Ali really appreciates about magic, the way game mechanics inspire character development in vice versa.
它带来了我们如果不渴望通过游戏机制来表达想法，就永远不会得到的设计和方向。我认为在卡牌上放置不同的故事是可能的，尽管我真的很喜欢我们现有的故事，但如果你在这些卡牌上没有任何故事，你就会失去游戏的灵魂。所以我带着两个问题进入了《万智牌》：为什么这款游戏在25年后依然如此受欢迎？卡牌游戏中的叙事作用是什么？我认为《万智牌》之所以如此受欢迎，不仅是因为卡牌内的故事或关于卡牌的故事，而是因为每次有人玩这些卡牌时都会产生全新的故事。
It takes the design and directions that we wouldn't necessarily ever get to without the desire to figure out how to express an idea through the mechanics of the game. I think that it would be possible to put different stories on, although I really love the stories that we've got, but if you didn't have any story on these cards, you'd be missing the soul of the game, really. So I came into Magic the Gathering, wondering two things. Why is this game still so popular 25 years later? And what is the role of storytelling in a card game? And I think that the reason why Magic has been so popular isn't just the story within the cards or the story about the cards, but the brand-new story that emerges every time someone plays the cards.
游戏的真实故事是发生在玩家身上的事情。Brady Dommermuth说这越来越罕见了。我的意思是，今天太多的电子游戏表现得像五小时的电影，给玩家的自主权很少。在一个许多游戏都是独自在电脑或主机前完成的时代，《万智牌》需要这种社区，它需要这种人类的存在。它的机制、游戏玩法和系统足够引人入胜，它想要抓住你的大脑，它想要你探索它的复杂性，但为了做到这一点，你必须与
The real story of a game is what happens to the player. And Brady Dahmer Mewth says that is increasingly rare. I mean so many video games today are behaving like five-hour movies that give the player very little autonomy. In an era where so many games are played alone in front of your PC or in front of your console, magic requires this community, it requires this human presence. It's compelling enough in its mechanics and its gameplay and systems, that it wants to hold on to your brain, it wants you to explore its complexities, but in order to do so, you have to interface with
其他人互动。正因为如此，它最终成为了一种自然传播的东西，如果我想看看我的新牌组是否有效，我就必须找到一个人来对战。换句话说，游戏的魔力在于现实世界的人际互动。而现实世界的人际互动在这些日子里是稀缺的。好了，本周节目就到这里。感谢收听。
other humans. And because of that, it ends up being this naturally viral thing, where if I want to see if my new deck works, I'm going gonna have to find somebody to play it against. In other words, the magic of the game is real world human interaction. And real world human interaction is in short supply these days. Well, that's it for this week. Thank you for listening.
特别感谢Nat Bale、Mark Rosewater、Allie Medwin、James Wyatt、Brady Dommermuth和Liz Leo。《万智牌》拥有一些最好的奇幻艺术作品，我甚至不觉得羞于承认这一点。我问Liz她是否有最喜欢的卡牌。我喜欢“Hydra Doodle”这张牌。它是一只九头蛇，但它也是一只贵宾犬。所有的头都在做着奇怪、疯狂的事情。
Special thanks to Nat Bale, Mark Rosewater, Allie Medwin, James Wyatt, Pretty Dahmer Muth, and Liz Leo. Magic has some of the best fantasy art out there, and I don't even feel a shame saying it. I asked Liz if she's any favorite cards. I love the card Hydra Doodle. It's this Hydra, but it's also a poodle. And all the heads are off doing weird crazy things.
风味文字是“less house broken than house breaking”（比起被驯化，更擅长拆家）。这很好。这是一张好牌。它真的很可爱。《Imaginary Worlds》由Eric Mollinsky和Stephanie Billman制作。你可以在imaginaryworldspodcast.org找到它。我们会在节目说明中提供链接。所以当谈到《万智牌》时，我的孩子们Carver和Maslow总是，
And the flavor text is less house broken than house breaking. That's good. It's a good card. It's really cute. Imaginary worlds is produced by Eric Mollinsky and Stephanie Billman. You can find it at imaginaryworldspodcast.org. We'll have a link in the show notes. So when it comes to magic in particular, my boys, Carver and Maslow, always,
总是有话要说。你们想说什么，孩子们？“你好，我叫Carver，我玩《万智牌》。我在赛制中最喜欢做的事情是尝试找到一种组合技，好到足以摧毁对手。它是无敌的。例如，‘Copycat’组合技。”
always have something to say. What do you guys say, boys? Hello, my name is Carver, and I play match of the other. My favorite thing to do in formats is you try to find a combo or something like that that is so good that it will end up destroying the 4 Rats. It's unbeatable. For instance, the Copycat combo.
“‘Copycat’组合技是指创造它的人找到了一种方法，在第4回合结束前制造出无限多的小猫来攻击，造成无限伤害。而且它在这一点上非常稳定，每次都能赢，结果没人能打败它，没人能找到打败它的方法，所有不玩这个牌组的人都输了，最终他们发现它太强了，两张牌都需要被禁掉，并从赛制中完全移除，这样它就不会再这样下去了。”
The Copycat combo is where the person who made it found a way to make infinite little cats to attack for infinite damage by a round of turn 4. And it was it was ridiculously consistent at it too and every time it won and it turns out that no one could beat it no one could find a way to beat it and everyone who didn't play the deck lost and eventually they found out that it was so good that both cards needed to be banned and taken out of the format entirely so that it wouldn't go on like this.
“所以你的目标是找到另一个这样的组合？”“是的，没错。”“我叫Maslow，我也玩《万智牌》。我更喜欢玩‘伊捷’（Izzet）颜色，也就是红色和蓝色。我喜欢玩很多瞬间（Instant）和法术（Sorcery）牌，而且我通常会为那种类型的牌组玩太多生物。瞬间牌的伟大之处在于你不需要在别人的回合等待。只要你有足够的法力，你就可以做任何事。”
And so your goal is to find another one of those. Yes it is. My name is Maslow and I also play Magic the Gathering. I prefer playing the Is it Colors, which are red and blue. I like to play a lot of Instance and Sorcery cards, and I normally play a little too many creatures for that type of deck. The great thing about Instance is that you don't need to wait around while other people's turns. You can do stuff as long as you have enough mana for it.
“你可以在别人的回合玩瞬间牌。你可以在别人的回合玩哪种瞬间牌的例子？”“例如，哈哈，懂了吗？有一张牌叫‘Sonic Assault’。你可以在别人的回合玩它。例如，嗯哼，懂了吗？嗯，有一张牌叫‘Sonic Assault’，我通常会在对手的回合他们攻击时玩这张牌，我会说，在攻击结算之前，”
You can play instances on other people's turns. What's an example of a type of Instance card you can play on someone else's turn? For instance, ha ha, get it? There's a card called Sonic Assault. you can play on someone else's turn. For instance, uh-huh, get it? Um, there's a card called Sonic Assault, and I normally would play this on an opponent's turn when they're attacking, and I'd say, before attacks resolve,
“我横置[此处插入生物名称]，这使得它无法攻击，作为额外奖励，该生物的控制者受到2点伤害，因为那是该卡牌的另一个功能。”“酷。”那是给你们这些老派死忠粉丝的。2019年快乐。《99% Invisible》是91.7 KALW的一个项目，
I tap insert creature name here, and that makes it so it can't attack, and as an added bonus, the controller of that creature takes two damage, because that's another feature of the card. Cool. That was for a few of you old-school diehard fans. Happy 2019. 99% invisible is a project of 91.7 KALW
在旧金山制作，并在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Radio Row录制。我们是PRX旗下RadioTopia的骄傲成员，这是一个由极具独立精神和迷人播客组成的集合，请在radiotopia.fm找到它们。下周有一个全新的内部制作节目，敬请期待。那是《Many Stories》第二部分。新年快乐。RadioTopia。
in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a collection of fiercely independent and fascinating podcasts, find them all at radiotopia.fm. There's a brand new show next week produced in-house, so stay tuned for that. It's many stories part two. Happy New Year. RadioTopia.
来自PRX。谢谢。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
From PRX. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。